[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight well they have got him
finally traps like John Dillinger
outside the Biograph theater by the
g-men Democrats announced today that
they have finally obtained proof
concrete and irrefutable proof that the
president is in fact a secret Russian
agent this president seems to be putting
Russia's interests ahead of our own the
evidence suggests indeed Trump is has
been a pawn of the Russians Donilon has
it nailed as we told you last night you
could have seen this coming
the FBI is suspected for some time the
bureau opened a criminal investigation
to the president more than a year ago on
the grounds that no loyal American would
fire a leader as impressive as FBI
director Jim Comey Putin must have
ordered it The Washington Post concurred
with this is one of that papers
columnist noted Trump has also quote
endorsed populism that's right populism
that is the stink of Russia all over it
it smells like vodka and day-old herring
so people in Washington have had their
suspicions for years now but now we know
for certain and we know because of a
stunning New York Times piece today in
it current and former administration
officials speaking of course from behind
the protective veil of anonymity because
honestly you don't know what the KGB or
whatever is called these days is capable
of doing to people to tell the truth but
they nevertheless divulge that on
multiple occasions over the last year
the president has privately floated the
idea of pulling United States out of
NATO let that sink in leaving NATO this
is a huge story or it would have been a
huge story in 1983 when the Soviet Union
still existed and it was still clear
what the point of NATO was NATO you'll
remember was created to keep the Soviets
from invading Western Europe and NATO
did a very good job of that all the way
until the very day the Soviet Union
collapsed that was the summer of 1991 it
was almost 28 years ago Vladimir Putin
runs Russia now he does not plan to
invade Western Europe he can't so why do
we still have NATO well nobody really
knows in Washington you're definitely
not allowed to
ask and that's a shame because it would
be an interesting conversation remaining
in NATO comes with significant
obligations in the 1990s our leaders
decided it would be a wise idea to
promise countries like Latvia and
Estonia that we would use nuclear
weapons to protect them if they ever had
a problem with Russia why did we do that
well who knows the details are lost to
history but the point is we did that
article 5 obligates the United States to
protect any NATO ally that is threatened
so how do we feel about that now are you
ready to launch a nuclear war over
Latvia what do you think of sending our
kids to defend the territorial integrity
of Estonia our foreign policy
establishment thinks it's well worth it
in fact under our current rules of
membership in NATO we would have no
choice you might have not have known
that all of this might merit a national
debate of some sort at some point when
we're ready 28 years in but no the left
is an international debates anymore
they're into screaming and threats and
criminal investigation and other forms
of coercion they like things the way
they are in this country they're
benefiting hugely from the status quo
and they don't like being challenged
they consider asking difficult questions
a criminal act just this morning in fact
Preet Bharara he's the most famous
former federal prosecutor in the country
explained this view on Twitter he said
this quote if true Trump should
immediately and publicly state his
apparent wish to withdraw from NATO so
he can be promptly impeached convicted
and removed from office
unquote in other words talking about
leaving NATO isn't simply unwise
according to our leaders it's an
impeachable offense lots of famous and
powerful people in Washington think this
watch we're drawing from NATO even
discussing discussion about the or
throwing for NATO I think is wood it
would be disastrous for the security I
think that act would be so destructive
to our country it would be a ground for
some profound of effort by our part
whether it's impeachment or the 25th
amendment he can't do that to this
country and I don't believe that he can
do it without Senate ratification
did you catch that the 25th amendment in
other words according to a sitting
member of Congress someone who's there
right now rethinking membership Pinedo
isn't just treasonous in criminal though
obviously it is it's also prima facie
evidence of insanity you're not fit to
govern if you say that you probably
shouldn't drive a car just in the
interest of public safety
so whatever happened to the old
Democratic Party when do the anti-war
people become flirted neocon so we need
to become the party of Bill Kristol and
max boot and every other discredited
hack still trying to replicate the Iraq
disaster in nations around the world who
knows when that happened but that's
exactly what the Democratic Party is
today just ask Tulsi Gabbard Gabbard is
a Democratic member of Congress she's
now running for president on most
questions she's a conventional liberal
she represents Hawaii after all of
course she is but on the question of
Syria she's skeptical Gabbard isn't
eager to overthrow the Assad government
why well because she worries about what
might come next what might happen to the
Christians than many other religious
minorities who live there for saying
that for holding that position she's
being denounced today by the left as a
monster
just this morning The Daily Beast tried
to link her to David Duke literally the
dumb people on TV are mad to watch them
she went in 2017 Gloria this is gonna be
another issue to visit with Bashar
al-assad in Syria and this trip has
already come back to bite her she did
apologize she did but you know how many
apologies can you make for bad judgment
not only what should be criticized
inside the Democratic Party but I think
it makes her less effective candidate I
mean you know she can't position herself
against Trump about meeting with
dictators when in fact she's done it
herself so you know I think she has some
I think she's gonna have some problems
[Applause]
that's the new standard in Washington
just so you know let's be crystal clear
about this you were not allowed to meet
with foreign dictators it's immoral in
fact it might be treason it could
trigger the 25th amendment unless it's I
don't know she's in ping of China yes
the Chinese government murders its
political opponents yes it has put
Muslims and concentration camps yes
they're languishing in those can
right now but it's not a huge deal to
meet with the Chinese the former
Governor of California Jerry Brown met
was gee just two years ago he praised
him as a leader in the fight against
global climate change even though China
is of course by far the world's biggest
polluter but whatever he may be a
dictator but he's a progressive dictator
and the left is not against those is
definitely for those in fact they're
role models in case you haven't figured
it out